Hey, it's Mike from Orderflows, and I'm
excited to introduce you to the
Orderflows Pressure Indicator. I'll be
walking you through the indicator in
this quick video. So, what I'm going to
cover is what the pressure detects and
why the passive traders matter in the
order flow. Talk a bit about multi-time
frame analysis, how you could overlay
higher or lower time frame signals on
your chart. I'll discuss the POC
movement detection, which shows you
volume acceptance and rejection. I'll
spend some time talking about the
momentum strength filter in the
Orderflows Pressure Indicator. So, you
know, you want to make sure you're
trading in the direction of momentum.
And, you know, most importantly, you
know, one thing you got to realize with
trading in indicators is sometimes
traders like to curve fit
something to the market. I'm going to
show you why pressure works across
markets without optimization. I'll show
you some charts from today and a few of
the previous days, and I'll show you how
you can get the Orderflows Pressure on
your charts today. So, what the
Orderflow Pressure detects is basically
it's looking for strong passive trading
in the market. So, the pressure occurs
when the market quickly runs into strong
passive buyers or sellers. It reads the
volume footprint chart and identifies
increasing volume on the passive side at
market extremes.
You're going to have two types of
pressure. You're going to have buy
pressure and sell pressure. Buy pressure
is increasing bid volume at lower
prices. Passive buyers are scaling in as
the market trades lower. They absorb
aggressive selling with increasing size
and the move often stalls. Markets rally
off the defended level. Sell pressure is
the opposite than buy pressure. So, you
got increasing offer volume at a higher
prices. Passive sellers are scaling in
as the market trades higher. They absorb
aggressive buying with increasing size.
The rally will often stall. Markets
sells
off from those defended levels. Now, for
those of you that aren't familiar with
me, my name is Michael Valtos, and I
spent over 20 years on institutional
trading desks. I spent 8 years as vice
president at J.P. Morgan, which is one
of the world's largest trading
operations.
Before that, I spent 3 years at
Commerzbank. I traded institutional flow
across European and global markets. I
spent about 4 years at Cargill, which is
a big physical and financial commodity
trading company, and we just trade on a
massive scale. EDF Man, I spent about 2
years there.
And, I you know, that's where I built
some experience in futures and commodity
markets.
And, about 10 years ago, I founded
Orderflows, bringing institutional grade
order flow tools to retail traders.
Now, there are two types of market
participants. Okay, you have aggressive
traders, you have passive traders. Think
of the aggressive traders as the force.
They're the ones that move the market.
The passive traders are sort of the wall
that stops movement. Aggressive traders
use market orders. They buy at the
offer, sell at the bid. They push price
in a direction, and it's what most
traders focus on.
However, passive traders,
they are the ones that determine the
outcome of the market. They use limit
orders. They wait for the market to come
to them. They absorb and defend price
levels.
>> [clears throat]
>> Now, what does that mean? Passive
traders determine market outcomes. Well,
when aggressive sellers push the market
lower and hit a level where passive
buyers are absorbing every contract with
increasing size, passive traders are
present. That's the moment that moves
stall.
That's the moment the reversals begin.
That's the level being defended. On
institutional desk, you know, we watch
for passive absorption at every key
level. It was one of the highest
conviction signals that we had. So, I
want to introduce you to the Orderflows
Pressure Indicator, which runs on
NinjaTrader 8.
It's a real-time indicator that detects
passive buying and selling pressure on
the volume footprint chart, showing you
exactly when and where passive traders
are stepping in to defend a level. It's
going to be able to detect passive
absorption in real time from the
footprint. It's going to identify
defended levels at turning points and
within moves. And, it's built from 20
years of institutional order flow
experience.
So, how it works? Well, you got buying
pressure, right? It's passive buyers are
being detected when the market trades
lower towards the low and the volume on
the bid side shows subsequent increases
at lower price levels, that is buy
pressure. So, you know, you have a
combination of aggressive sellers
pushing price lower and passive buyers
stepping in with increasing volume on
the bid. Each lower level sees more
volume than the last. You know, the
sellers are going to end up exhausting
themselves against that wall of passive
buying, and the market will often
stabilize and rally off the defending
level.
Sell pressure is the opposite of buy
pressure, right? And, when sell passive
sellers are detected, then you have a
pressure signal. So, when the market
trades high towards a high
and the volume on the offer side shows
subsequent increases at higher price
levels, that is sell pressure. So,
what's taking place is aggressive buyers
push the price higher. Passive sellers
step in with increasing volume on the
offer.
Each higher level sees more volume than
the last. Buyers exhaust themselves
against the wall of passive selling, and
the market will often stall and reverses
off the
the defended level. Okay? And, you know,
you could just see this little picture
here on the side. You know, as price is
going up, it's running into more and
more volume.
Now, that doesn't happen in every single
bar, but when it does happen, you know,
you got to start paying attention to it.
Now, it's just not based off of
increasing volume. There's other things
that are added to it in the algo. So,
let's go over a couple examples. So,
here's buying pressure at a swing low.
Right, you can see down here at the
swing low, we got this bullish signal
and the market, you know, had a nice run
up over the next 10 minutes. This is a
30 60-second 1-minute chart in E MES,
actually.
Um here we have selling pressure at
resistance, right? We have the high of
the day. The market is sort of butting
up against it, and we have selling
pressure coming in just right off the
high of the day before the market sells
off 20 points.
Now,
we talk about buying pressure and
selling pressure at reversal points. You
know, that's great, but you could also
have it within moves. And, you know, I
often
tell traders, you know, you should keep
two types of charts open. One chart for
reversals, one chart for momentum. You
know, so when the market is moving and
you're involved, you know, you want to
be participating in that move. And, you
can see here these
magenta down arrows are bearish signals
on the down move, and these blue up
triangles
are
bullish momentum on the up moves. Okay?
Now, we have some filters on there like
delta confirmation, delta divergence,
POC, swings, etc. I could go through all
those, but that it's quite robust. Um
this is, you know, where we have delta
confirmation, meaning, you know, the
delta's got to be positive as well as a
pressure signal. Okay? So, what this
does is, you know, it filters out those
bars where the delta is not coinciding
with
the pressure signal. For whatever
reason, you know, I mean, maybe there's,
you know, early at one point in the bar,
um you know, there was the opposite
order flow, right? We we really want to
focus on the bars that have order flow
going in the same direction.
Now, here's the beauty, right? The
Orderflows Pressure Indicator works on
your normal candlestick chart. Okay? So,
if you don't want to read a footprint
chart, you don't have to. You can put
the indicator on your existing chart
that you're already using for trading,
whether it's, you know, a a 1-minute
chart,
you know, a range-based chart, um you
know, volume or tick-based chart, even a
reversal bar chart, right? You don't
have to use the order flow footprint
chart, the volume footprint chart,
because what the Orderflows Pressure
Indicator is doing is it's reading all
that information that goes into forming
the footprint chart,
and it does its calculations, and it
just plots it on a normal candlestick
chart, right? That's the that's the real
power of it.
Now, there are three game-changing
features I want to talk about that, you
know, I really think take the Orderflows
Pressure to a higher level. Okay? So,
first one is multi-time frame analysis,
which allows you to overlay higher or
lower time frame pressure signals
directly on your existing chart. So, for
example,
you know, if you want to see 5-minute
signals, but basically signals based off
of 5-minute analysis, but you're using a
1-minute chart, you can take those
signals from the 5-minute chart and plot
them on your 1-minute chart. We have POC
movement detection. So, you're going to
track where the POC is shifting. You're
going to detect,
you know, volume acceptance, market
rejection, and, you know, maybe you can
find some early reversal signals.
We have a momentum strength filter. So,
you're going to be trading in the
direction of momentum, right? So,
pressure
now analyzes the order flow price action
and momentum together, right? And And
that's important, right? Everyone says
you got to trade, you know, the trend is
your friend. Trade in the direction of
the trend, and this just helps keep you
on the right side.
So, the multi-time frame analysis
feature is, you know, you'll be able to
trade higher time frame order flow
analysis on your existing chart. Now, I
did say you can trade lower time frame,
and but, you know, I know most people
like to use
the higher time frame and
find those levels and add them to their
chart. So, it allows you to overlay
different time frame or chart analysis
to give you a completely new perspective
on your current analysis. You know,
again, for example, 5-minute pressure
signals on your 1-minute chart, or maybe
you want to go the opposite direction.
You could add 30-second pressure signals
to your 1-minute chart.
And, why this changes everything is
you know, you're going to see higher
time frame context on your execution
chart, the chart that you execute your
trades on. So, you're going to see where
the 5-minute or 15-minute pressure
signals are firing while you trade the
1-minute chart. You know, the higher
time frame signals often carry more
weight. Now, you can see them without
leaving your execution chart. You know,
if you're going And lower time frame,
it's going to give you more precise
entries, right? Add a 30-second or
tick-based pressure signals to your
chart for micro level passive detection.
Find precise entry points within the
larger move.
You're going to have confluence against
different time frames. So, when your
current chart and the higher time frame
both show pressure at the same level,
the signal has multi-time frame uh
confirmation. That's significantly
higher conviction.
So, you have one chart, multiple
perspective, no more flipping between
charts trying to piece together what's
happening on different time frames.
Everything is layered on one screen.
So, you know, here's an example. This is
an E-mini 1-minute chart, but it's
showing
signals based off of the 5-minute chart.
It helps clean up some of those messier
charts, you know, where
um
you know, in in this time period, you
know, with everything going on in the
Middle East, you know, markets look a
bit volatile and sometimes, you know,
you see a lot of signals and you want to
go to a slightly higher time frame, but
you want to stay on your existing chart.
This is how you do it.
Now, the POC movement analysis function,
right? It's it's the ultimate edge,
right? Because you're going to see where
the market is placing its conviction,
right? Through POC, right? Remember,
volume is the fuel that drives price.
Without sufficient volume, price
movements are unsustainable. POC
movements show you exactly where the
market is placing its conviction, giving
you the ultimate edge in determining
which moves will stick and which will
fail.
So, you're going to look for volume
acceptance, right? POC shifting higher
with rising prices. Maybe you're going
to see a market rejection where POC
starts migrating lower with falling
prices. It's going to give you
conviction analysis. You're going to
trend in acceptance across bars. You
know, maybe um for reversals, you know,
price and POC move in the opposite
direction and that's maybe not a trade
that you want to take.
So, why POC helps analysis is it's going
to show you that volume acceptance, like
I said, POC shifts higher with rising
prices. Traders are accepting and
embracing elevated price levels. The
move has conviction behind it. This
confirms the rally is real.
It's going to show you market rejection.
POC migrating lower with falling prices.
Traders are only willing to participate
at reduced levels. Selling pressure is
genuine and sustainable. The move down
has legs. It's going to give you
conviction analysis. Monitor current and
previous bars to identify trends in
market acceptance. You can see when
buying or selling conviction is
strengthening or weakening before the
crowd catches on.
So, here's
the euro currency signals, right? Not
just your normal signals, but signals
that are using the POC movements, okay?
And you know, you can see it's catching
a lot of these nice sell-offs and some
of these
uh nice rallies here, right? And and
that's what it gives you cuz it's going
to it's it's an extra tool in your
arsenal to say you're trading with
volume in the direction that volume is
moving. Now, the momentum strength
filter keeps you in the trade
when there's momentum in the market. So,
trade in the direction of the momentum,
right? That's what you should always be
looking to do. The order flow pressure
now analyzes
order flow and price action and momentum
together. So, when momentum aligns with
the pressure signal, it reinforces the
validity of the trade. When momentum
diverges, it's telling you to pass. Now,
there's four strength levels. Zero is
disabled. One is, you know, basically
the minimum.
Three is average. So, that's sort of
balanced filtering. It's a recommended
starting point. Six is the strongest.
It's only the highest momentum signals
um
will show up.
Now, what momentum adds to the order
flow pressure indicator is it can it's a
confirmation signal. So, when momentum
aligns with a pressure signal, it
reinforces validity. Passive absorption
and the market has momentum in the same
direction. That should give you a higher
conviction trade. If momentum diverges,
so when momentum opposes the pressure
signal, it's a warning. The passive
detection may be valid, but the broader
market dynamics aren't supporting the
trade, so stay out.
Market psychology, right? Momentum
reflects the collective sentiment of
traders. It shows you the underlying
forces driving the market and combined
with passive detection, you see both the
structure and the energy. It's going to
give you better entry timing. By
filtering signals through momentum, you
enter trades that have both passive
support and directional energy. You're
going to have fewer signals, but
significantly higher quality signals.
Right? And that's the whole point,
taking higher quality trades.
See See here, I got these are just, you
know, um this is crude oil, right? Crude
oil we know is is moving. Doesn't look
like a big move, but this is a move from
all the way up to 9860. So, this is
about a
$4 move and you want to be trading in
that direction, right? It's not giving
you any short signals on that rally up,
that $4 rally up.
Until we hit the turning point and the
market starts selling off.
Now, this is important. No curve fitting
is required. You know, a lot of a
problem with a lot of indicators is you
have to curve fit them for your market,
right? You find the best settings that
worked in the past and hope they work in
the future. That is a recipe for
disaster. Pressure is different. It
reads the actual volume being traded at
the bid and offer at each level. It's
not calculating a formula from price
history. It's reading the live auction,
the actual order flow happening right
now. Now, traditional indicators
calculate from past price data. They
require optimization per market.
Settings that worked yesterday may fail
tomorrow. Now, the order flow's pressure
reads live bid offer volume. No
optimization needed. Works across
markets because it reads the actual
auction process.
Now, everything in the order flow's
pressure
is listed here, right? You got all these
nice features, right? The multi-time
frame analysis, the POC movement
detection, momentum strength, trade
entry signal, pressure sensitivity
levels.
POC filter, delta confirmation, delta
divergence, visual signal zones, a
look-back filter, um bar threshold
volume.
Um we have a very comprehensive user
guide that explains all the settings. It
works on NinjaTrader 8 on any futures
market. There's no curve fitting
required and you're going to get instant
delivery.
So, five ways pressure gives you an edge
is one, it's going to uh help identify
reversals at swing highs and lows before
price confirms. You're going to discover
defended levels that become key support
and resistance. You're going to be able
to confirm breakouts and fake outs by
checking for passive defense. Manage
trades and time exits based on passive
support or opposition. You're going to
read the internal dynamics of trending
moves.
Trading with or without pressure? Well,
if you don't have the order flow
pressure indicator, you're going to rely
on lagging indicators. You're not going
to be able to see passive absorption.
You're going to fall for fake breakouts.
You're going to exit too early or hold
too long. You're going to miss the
internal dynamics of the market. But
with the order flow's pressure, you're
going to see passive absorption in real
time. You're going to be able to
identify turning points early. You're
going to filter genuine versus fake
breakouts. You're going to hold with
confidence
because you're going to see when levels
are defended
and you're going to read the full battle
at each level.
So, to get the order flow's pressure
indicator today, just go to
www.orderflows.com/pressure.
It's a one-time payment, only $269. You
get a lifetime license and all future
updates are included. So, again, go to
www.orderflows.com/pressure
or click on the link below to get
started and I'll see you guys on the
inside.